today it got better for gay people
across the u.s. in a historic decision
the Supreme Court struck down the
remaining same-sex marriage bans in 13
states
but while the rainbow flags are flying
high the celebration is far from
unanimous the court was divided 5 to 4
on the decision and in many states
politicians are promising to fight back
and for those who are celebrating
same-sex marriage is only one step in
the fight for equality while marriage
Recognition brings a host of benefits
same-sex couples and individuals still
face discrimination in many other areas
there is no federal law protecting LGBTQ
people from housing discrimination in 29
states don't have along the books
protecting those looking for housing and
in these states employers can legally
fire or refuse to hire someone based on
their sexual orientation or gender
identity only California and New Jersey
and DC banned the practice of conversion
therapy which has been rejected by
mainstream medical organizations and
even though a record number of Americans
support same-sex marriage homosexuality
is not universally accepted and that can
have real consequences especially for
young people LGBTQ students report
feeling unsafe in school because of
bullying or harassment lesbian bisexual
and gay youth are four times more likely
to attempt suicide than their straight
counterparts kids and teens who come out
may be rejected by their families an
estimated 40% of homeless youth are
LGBTQ despite that attitudes towards
homosexuality have changed dramatically
over the last few years but for many in
the gay community the Supreme Court
ruling is just a start every feminie
kids office said ok
so you will feel guilty you will feel
sad for being gay